i sold an nft of my meme for
600 000 and this is that story my name
is chris torres but you may know me as
the creator of nancat
so this all started around the year 2010
one day i was walking through a pet
store and i just saw this beautiful
russian blue kitten
and you know i just decided to take him
it was just so cute to not adopt
and i named him marty and he was my baby
he was always there for me he was the
craziest
most fastest cat ever he was just always
running around the house
and actually he would just kind of roam
the neighborhood he was always on an
adventure of some sort
such a beautiful soul of a cat he was
such a great cat
and i ended up incorporating marty into
a lot of my comics i've been drawing
comics for a long time now called lol
comics and he just kind of became a
featured character in my series
so around 2011 a lot of natural
disasters were happening around the
world a lot of typhoons a lot of
earthquakes
and i saw a lot of artists actually
begin to do like donation drives for the
american red cross
doctors without borders and a few other
charities and then um i decided to join
in
at the time i didn't really have much of
a following but i would just
hop on to live stream at least once a
day so now i'd be like hey everybody
what do you want me to draw one day it
was just kind of slow nobody was really
in there so i kind of asked everybody
involved um you know what do you guys
want to see
and all the words you know all the
keywords started popping up i saw cat
i saw rainbows i saw breakfast pastry
so i just started doodling what
ended up being yan cat it was just a cat
with a breakfast pastry body
and at the time the trail wasn't going
behind them it was just kind of going
all over the place
i got a like 100 tip that day and which
went straight to charity which was
awesome uh i drew it and then i went to
sleep that night i
and i just kind of dreamt a scenario
where
the doodle that i had drawn with marty
flying through space kind of was like
animated and pixelated in my head and i
just kind of woke up i remember it was
almost midnight
that night i woke up and i was like i
have to do this it's still fresh in my
mind
so i you know i ran downstairs and i
began drawing and it took about
it took about six hours i know i know
the sun was coming up by the time i
finished
so i posted it on tumblr and uh
overnight it had thousands of notes and
it's just lots of messages of people
just saying how much they loved it a few
days passed and then it ended up being
on youtube
the user sarah june actually uploaded
nyanka with the
popular song from danielle called you
know the nyani and yanian song
and that's where it really just like
exploded into the mainstream
lots of people were inspired by mancat
and ended up being this huge global
phenomenon
i did show marty the animation he was
very cat-like in his response where he
just didn't care
i want to say around january of 2021
this year
i had a good friend of mine named lizzie
she actually contacted me and was like
look all these people
are creating artwork in the nft market
making not only money but making
themselves known
i think the easiest way to uh explain
nfts
it's like a digital signature that can't
be replicated it ties
the artwork to you everybody will know
on the blockchain
that this artist created this artwork
there's nobody that can make a forgery
and get away with it the first nan cats
sold for six hundred thousand dollars i
held all the rights to the ncat and like
copyrights and the trademarks and stuff
like that
the owner of the nft itself basically
got a promise for me that this nft
will be the only one based on the
original video
ever the person that owns it now is
basically holding on to
you know basically a trading card and
from there he can sell it for
however much he or she wants in the
future if nyancat continues to be
popular in the
years to come the owner can actually
sell it for millions of dollars if they
choose to
to somebody that wants to buy it the the
best thing about it though is that
whenever somebody sells your nft
that you created you actually do get a
percentage of it uh after that i started
making
other damn cats i started collaborating
with artists in the nft space
i helped zoe sell her and of tea and
actually helped harold get his
nft set up and then after that i created
what i call the nancat
classic collection which is based off of
old nan cats that i created
back in 2011 or so and i just never
released so i've actually sold
i want to say over 700 more nfts since
the original nan cat
we're kind of in talks for a possible tv
show we're talking about possible new
games i'm very excited for the future
for it and i hope that dan cat
still has a place 10 years from now back
in 2012 marty
ended up becoming sick he ended up
having fip
and he sadly passed away that year and
it was really sad um we tried
we tried so hard to save him but there
was just nothing that really could be
done
but it's also kind of cool that his
legacy lives on
i will always look at the image of dan
cat flying around and i will always see
marty like
that is the behavior that he had just
zooming around all the time and i could
totally see him right now just in space
flying around
with just rainbows everywhere
[Music]
you